hello everyone and welcome to another
game you guys requested also from the
blitz section of the saint louis rapid
blitz tournament this is the first day
of the blitz and today it's going to be
the second day of the blitz so all of
the games will be repeated only with
colors reversed and here uh
the young frenchman will face uh sam
shankland uh in a in quite an
interesting game you guys requested this
one so let's uh let's check it out uh
alireza has the white pieces and again
he opens with c4 he goes for the english
opening like he did against dianne
ponashi we have e6 by sam uh g3 and now
pawn to d5 the agincourt defense bishop
to g2 and now knight to f6 with knight
to f3 bishop to e7 and both players
castle so this is a fairly fairly
standard uh position that you will see
in hundreds even thousands of games and
usually moves like d4 will be seen also
b3 queen to c2 uh but the move alireza
plays is a fairly rare one he plays d3
and now uh of course sam could just go d
captures and see four force a queen
thread but he doesn't really gain all
that much characters captures captures
captures and okay white will put a
bishop on f4 uh it's gonna be a nice
position but not not a very ambitious
one so instead after d3 sam goes for c5
as a few people know just theory as much
as sam shankland so he strikes with it
with what is best
we have c captur d5 while there is a e
captures and now only now advancing the
pawn all the way to d4 we have knight to
c6 knight to c3 and now knight to e4 uh
trying to get this
knight to this very active square and
then what you are hoping for is for
alireza of course to capture then you
get your pawn here you kick away the
knight from f3 and then you cement the
e4 pawn with f5 uh and the captures on
c5 is a known move uh in the position
but here alireza plays bishop to e3 and
it is now already as of move tender we
have a completely new game and this is
the position that usually interests us
in all of the games that we check out
now as these are blitz games um now of
course we're not gonna analyze them as
deeply as we do rapid games and not
nearly as deeply as we analyze classical
games uh so most of the time when i go
into some sort of a weird deep line it's
not because i think players missed it
it's just because it's a fun line and i
thought you guys might enjoy it
so here uh uh sam goes for a trade
knight captures on c3 b captures and now
now he makes a choice he goes for c4 so
he abandons the fight for the center but
he does grab more space here he now
controls b3 and d3 and if alireza can
safely execute e4 at some point this
will undermine the structure if not then
sound will have a very very long term
advantage so here queen b1 uh putting
the queen on this long diagonal and also
just hindering the development of the
light square bishop as the b7 pawn would
hang so g6 sam says all right i'm going
to play rogue b8 defend my pawn and play
bishop to f5 to attack your queen and
develop my bishop with tempo knights the
e5 and now uh bishop to d6
we have bishop to f4 now uh and rook to
b8 so now you are uh most likely ready
to play bishop to f5 but here alireza
beats him to it he plays queen to b5 uh
and now we have knight to e7 here uh
basically the cleanest way to play this
is bishop to e6 and then uh probably why
why sam decided against it is that this
bishop to h6 movie is very annoying
going after the rook and now there are
so many tricky moves here that you have
to calculate you just don't have time to
do uh all of them you have to calculate
knight captures and if you have to
calculate a a6 you have to calculate
bishop captures an e5 uh but i'm just
going to show you now what's uh what's
true in the position and that is pawn to
a6 so first you challenge the queen and
then uh of course if knight captures on
c6 which is white's best reply going
after the black queen you just trade
eight captures on b5 knight captures
here and now you save your rook with
rook character 78 and you have a fine
position both players still have the
bishop pair and okay the b pawn is
doubled but should be should be okay so
this is possible uh but sam went for
knight to the e7 and now alireza goes
for this very annoying bishop to h6 move
uh he doesn't go for bishop captures on
d5 it's a clean pawn you can take it uh
but alireza doesn't want it he plays
bishop to h6 uh a6 now chasing away the
queen and now queen to b2 we have rook
to e8 uh getting the uh rook out of
harm's way and now pawn to e4 so like we
said if you can pull this off without um
black having some sort of a way to
punish you you will be okay the problem
is there is a way for sam to punish this
e4 push and um it seems that it does
come a bit too early but again it's
blitz and you don't have time to
calculate a move like f6 uh it's just a
crazy crazy move uh of course it's in
the position and of course everyone's
thinking about it uh but you know that
whenever you play it you lose so
naturally you don't want to play it but
the problem here is uh if alireza just
uh okay and maybe elvis i wanted to play
something like f4 and he wanted to go go
for the attack or something the problem
with this move is that d captures on e4
and white has nothing uh if bishop
captures an e4 you're just going to play
bishop f5 he's just going to continue
development and only after let's say
bishop captures knight captures now uh
the problem is that the bishop on h6 is
hanging and the pawn on f4 is preventing
the bishop from going back so you don't
really have a a good move here you have
to play something like knight to g4 then
knight captures knight captures king g7
knight will go back and then queen d7
black sold all of his problems uh and uh
well he will enjoy a much better
position so the only way to uh play uh
this f6 idea is to go back knight to f3
but still it's not very ambitious d
captures an e4 uh grabbing the pawn and
now if knight to d2 going after this
pawn and the c4 pawn now comes knight to
f5 again the problem is the bishop here
and now the knight even prevents the
bishop from escaping so you have to put
the bishop on a silly square like e3 and
then comes knight captures f captures
and pawn to f5 and black again has a
very very
nice position so that's the problem now
with e4 basically the the bishop on h6
is the problem so here d captures an e4
by sam but now it's a bit a different
knight captures on c4 biology attacking
the bishop bishop the c7 sam of course
wants to keep the bishop pair and now
rook f to e1 putting pressure on on the
e4 pawn uh you could also uh capture it
right away but uh ali is a preferred
development over over just grabbing a
pawn so bishop to e6 going after the
knight and not knight to a3 a bit of a
passive square for the knight but he has
plans of bringing it back maybe knight
to c to knight e3 then who knows where
the knight might end up so knights the
f5 finally going after aldi reza's
bishop on h6 and now bishop all the way
back to d2
and now uh sam plays knight back to d6
which is a fine move but there is also
the the the very aesthetically pleasing
knight stage for the bishop pair uh here
is just the spectacular so you might
even consider a move like this the the
knight can never be captured so now
basically you would only have to decide
whether you want to move the bishop or
you want to allow sam to capture this
bishop with knight captures on g2
because if you capture them queen
captures and then you just get destroyed
so it was uh
definitely a nice move uh but okay
knight to d6 and now bishop to f4 by
alireza
0.5 now
uh sam cements his pawn structure here
the e4 pawn is now uh very very strong
and now alireza plays the only move in
the position that basically uh
stops uh sam from just uh taking over
this game and that is pawn to d5 it's a
pawn sacrifice that really should not be
accepted if you if you accept it uh then
for example bishop captures rocated d1
you align the rook with the bishop with
the queen c4 is coming you're gonna open
up this diagonal uh hopefully play
bishop to h6 uh yeah there will be some
checkmating threats you will give
alireza so much activity for for the
price of that one pawn and in blitz you
generally don't want to take pawns
unless you're like twice as strong as
your opponent then it's okay to take
pawn so here bishop back to f7 uh and
now alaiza goes pawn to c4 so now the
pawns are even stronger but the diagonal
for the white queen has opened up and
now bishop to h6 will be
uh well will be an unstoppable threat
and of course the g5 has to be played
but now alireza plays the even more
brilliant bishop to e5 and now the
problem is if this is not addressed and
rook captures an e5 is the only move
let's say you play something you play b5
we just play bishop h8 and there is no
defense against queen uh g7 checkmate
now you just have to give up a clean
rook so this is how sam decides to play
it he decides to capture it rook
captures an e5 and this is the only way
to play queen captures an e5 and now
uh you can still maybe survive this with
some engine precise play like bishop b6
to c5 to block the pawns and then you
know just hope for the best
but again this is blitz knight captures
and c4 was played which makes sense you
open up an attack on the queen you also
threaten to pick up the knight but
alireza just plays the only winning move
and that is queen captures on f5 he
gives up the knight here
but it doesn't matter as the bishop now
will assume this diagonal and then the
queen bishop combo will be too deadly so
knight captures on a3 doesn't really
matter what you play so you might as
well grab a piece bishop capture sunny
for threatening queen captures on h7 and
now bishop to g6 and now there really is
no good way to
uh to
defend even bishop to g6 which seems
like a good move isn't because now all
it is just plays bishop to a queen to e6
check kink the g7 and now it seems like
you don't have any uh useful checks uh
but you have as many as you want because
here all it is just played bishop
captures on g6 and he was in this
position on move 31 that sam shanklin
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh now all it is is
just up material and if you accept the
bishop then you're gonna be
uh down even more material uh so here
for example of course king captures is
impossible the queen also covers the g6
square and if h captures on g6 then you
have this queen e7 check that's why sam
resigned connecting not only with the
bishop but also with the knight on a3 so
if you move the king i just queen
captures an a3 and there's no playing
this you have two rooks and the queen
against the real queen and bishop and
the black king is in a terrible spot
here even if you grab the pass pawn rook
ad1 and the white is just much better
here
and the other thing after queen a7 if
you trade queens then just rook captures
on e7 and then the bishop hangs so
it seems like no square is a good square
for this bishop king h6 let's say rook
captures on c7 and again the end game is
completely winning for alireza
so
as we always say the blitz blitz is more
about speed and cunning than it is about
uh calculating and grabbing pawns and
here uh the alireza was was a
much much uh faster and he was a a bit
more cunning than sam sam also uh had a
fine position but uh that that in that
critical moment uh where it seemed like
sand uh sam solidified and it seemed
like everything was perfectly fine all
it is i spotted the d5 pawn uh offering
or followed by c4 opening up this
diagonal brush page six and then
everything just falls apart for sam
because without the dark square bishop
defending and the dark square bishop and
c7 isn't really a part of this game like
if it was on g7 uh then it would be a
different story but on c7 not so much
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nicely done by alireza
who not only uh was leading the
tournament after the three days of rapid
but it's also now leading after one day
of blitz uh so sorry about that we're
gonna check that out as well but these
are the standings after uh three days of
rapid and uh one day of blitz
so the two frenchmen alireza and maxine
vashilagrav are are in the lead alireza
with 15 points followed by maxine with
13 and a half then jeffrey sheehan with
13 yanipanishi with 12 and a half and
then he covered nakamura who was last
after three days of rapid now emerges in
fifth uh as he had an incredible
incredible day of blitz out of nine
blitz games he did not lose a single one
uh he won six games and drew three and
uh once again proved that he is uh
definitely uh rightly and
you know rightly uh uh deserved the
highest rated blitz player in the world
then fabiano corrano levon and shakhtar
mahmoud are with 11 and a half sam
shankler with 11 and linear dominguez
with eight and a half and there is one
more day of incredible blitz action so
we'll see if alireza can take this all
the way or maybe someone will catch up
to me if he felt it as if
hikaru pulls another day like this it
could be very close and of course maxime
also playing incredibly incredible chess
and these are the live blitz ratings if
you guys are interested in that so you
can see nakamura is the highest rated
blitz player in the world currently he
won almost 40 points in this event uh
then uh arunyan in second already in
third karwana in fort artemyev uh in
fifth and magnus only in sixth place but
as you can see uh no no points for him
he's currently not playing any blitz
games but he did uh sort of uh
uh to maybe mess with hikaru a little
bit he did uh log into chess.com and
overtook hikaru as the highest rated uh
player uh blitz per on chess.com that
was i guess sort of a response to hikaru
on you know
having so many so many points in actual
live rating and also now as chess.com
owns uh absolutely everything in the
world uh makes sense for magnus the uh i
played there as well uh and then you
have uh okay uh geary in eighth of a
maxi version of gravity knight daniel
dubois intent and uh and so on and so on
these are the top 25 uh the bliss
players in the world
uh so yeah that's the game and the live
ratings and the standings hope you guys
enjoyed that uh i would like to thank
damon targaryen gary sharma
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the saint
louis blitz tournament until it finishes
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do use hashtag suggestion if you have
any games that you would like me to
cover
see you soon